very happy to welcome president duques
here
today what a pleasure
and it's a pleasure to host a really
close friend and like-minded partner
so
today we have not only many joint
projects but we have something very
concrete
we are signing today the
commissioner zinke which is and minister
correa
the joint declaration on environment
climate action and sustainable
development
colombia has a
vast ecological wealth this is very
impressive and thus is an indispensable
partner in the fight against climate
change and our transition towards action
for the environment
we both share a strong determination
what that is concerned and we will work
hand in hand
on our green agenda so today's
declaration is another important step
in that same direction thank you very
much and a very warm welcome again well
thank you so much madam president it's a
great honor to be
visiting you here in brussels
and i want to first of all thank you and
congratulate you for your leadership in
the climate action policies that are
needed today
from our point of view
this is not only a very important
declaration
but a clear joint commitment to protect
our planet
there is no planet b
and we have to take bold actions
as we very well expressed in glasgow
colombia has set the goal to become our
carbon neutral country by 2050
and to reduce
our greenhouse has its emissions by 51
in 2030.
but we have also made a very bold
statement that i mentioned it in brest
with you last week
and it is that colombia in this year
2022
will
show the world
that we will declare 30 of our territory
as a protected area
this implies not only maritime territory
but on land territory
and also expanding our national parks
we have been embracing the circular
economy policy
we have been promoting the energy
transition with the support of the
european union and in fact we're passing
from 0.2 percent of our energy matrix in
non-conventional renewables to get to
more than 18
by the end of this year
this makes colombia a leader worldwide
in energy transition
we have also made a strong emphasis in
clean mobility and we have reached
already the target that we discussed
with the eu when our administration
began
to have more than 6 000 electric
vehicles in colombia's roads
and i should also mention that your
support
i'm president the support of the eu has
been in very relevant for a country that
is the second most biodiverse country in
the world
to protect
high altitude ecosystems
more than 50 percent of the world
paramus and high altitude ecosystems are
present in colombia
35 of our territory is amazonic land
and the european union has contributed
decisively in the latinia pact to
protect the amazon
and last but not least
i should
i want to express my gratitude for your
support to the artemis campaign
a campaign that was launched by all the
colombian public force
in order to protect ecosystems since we
included in our national security
strategy the protection of biodiversity
as one of our main priorities
and i also want to express
not only my recognition
but the importance and the pivotal role
that the eu is playing in what we call
the savia training or education campaign
around the country
to train youngsters and leaders in the
protection of the environment
so this declaration and this statement
that we're about to sign
only demonstrates that we have reached
the highest peak in the relationship
between colombia and the european union
as we both also express it during the
united nations general assembly i am
delighted to be in brussels to be with
you signing this declaration
and to demonstrate the importance of
what we have achieved
and i have to say something also ursula
here with you
today we're sharing with the colombian
people
one of the most important best news we
have received in quite some time
we have worked this morning
with our team from the ministry of
finance in colombia
and our team at the presidency
and we have evaluated the numbers of
growth
in the month of december 2021
and i want to express this from brussels
to the colombian people
that in year 2021
the colombian economy grew
above
10.2 percent
and this means
that we have reached the highest
economic growth in a republican history
it demonstrates our resilience and it is
very important to say
that it is growth with sustainability
and that's why sharing those very
important news with my fellow citizens
with you at my side as a supporter of
all this recovery policy also emphasizes
that this recovery is taking place
hand-in-hand with a very strong
sustainability and climate action agenda
thank you very much thank you thank you
thank you ma'am